hi everyone Stan here from civils Ai and
welcome to the AI in construction course
so um I hope you're ready and excited to
learn about python Ai and Automation in
construction because we've going to have
all of that here so this is lesson
number one and in this lesson what we're
going to be doing is explaining the
structure of the course what exactly
you're going to be learning and your
overall objectives so what you want to
gain from this course so without further
Ado let's get started so in total we're
going to have seven lessons at part of
this course and there's going to be a
mix of both practical sessions when
we're building things and working on
things together building applications
and also some Theory but there'll be
much more emphasis on practical sessions
where we're actually building things uh
so lesson one is going to be an
introduction to the course and the
objectives of the course lesson two is
going to be some Theory where I'm
explaining to you about the history and
the fund mentals of AI technology the
idea behind this is that you're going to
gain a deep level of understanding of
how these foundational models so the
lowest level of AI model creation uh how
that works how those are built and then
also how the AI applications are layered
on top of that and how they allow us to
interact with these models and solve our
different issues and pain points so
lesson two will be on the fundamentals
and then lesson three we're going to
start applying the fundamental straight
away in Practical sessions so we're
going to be starting with no code
Solutions so we're going to be building
two different AI applications for
different construction use cases but
we're not going to be coding at all
we're just going to do this with no code
applications one of the applications
we're going to build is going to be for
Construction contract reviews so we're
going to take the PDF of a Construction
contract and we're going to analyze that
for the risky Clauses or some
unfavorable Clauses in the contract and
create a table of a risk ass assessment
for that contract and also draft a
renegotiation email around those
problematic or troubling cause Clauses
we're also going to build another
application which is going to take a
bunch of site photos that have been
taken on a construction site and draft
that into an inspection report an
inspection word report so it's going to
understand what's in the photos and it's
going to start writing out um an
inspection report for us
automatically Lesson Four we're going to
start in ucing python so I'm going to
we're going to start very basic um in
fact all you're going to need is some
very P basic Python Programming skills
which I'm going to teach you so you can
actually do this course without any
knowledge of python um so I'm going to
start explaining some very basic python
scripting we can do and then how we can
actually interact with some AI large
language models uh via python so it's
only going to take a few lines of code
for us to get that set
up I'm then going to explain how you can
actually publish uh AI applic to the web
so how we can use streamlit which is a
great tool for publishing free AI
applications on the internet um how we
can use that to actually publish some of
the code we've been working on really
easily I'm then going to explain about
fine-tuning our AI applications for
different construction use cases so the
object one of the objectives of this
course is we're going to build four
different AI applications ourselves um
which is going to be an AI for CAD so
this is is going to be an application
which takes PDF CAD drawings and
automatically generates an Excel bill of
quantities or a material takeoff from
what can be seen in that CAD drawing
we're then going to build an AI for
civil engineering which will be very
similar to the no code tool we've
already built but we're going to be
building this in Python so we're going
to have more control and flexibility and
this is going to create a word
inspection report from site photos we're
then going to build an AI for
contractors which is again similar to
the no code app we've already built for
analyzing construction contracts for
risk for risks and generating that draft
renegotiation email um and again this is
going to have more flexibility and
finally one of my personal favorites um
which is actually an AI for Architects
which can take photos of a building take
your bunch of photos you've taken of a
building and it can restyle that both
the interior and the exterior of the
building between different styles so
this could help a lot with refurbishment
projects restyling rooms testing out
different styles so these are the four
applications we're going to build and
we're going to learn how to publish
those on the web and finally um we have
a theory lesson which will be on AI
safety and regulations I'm going to
explain to you about all of the latest
regulations in the AI world and what
this means for both us as potentially AI
developers and also us as AI users so to
just explain why we created this course
basically we saw online that there's a
lot of misinformation or a lot of qu low
quality information relating to Ai and
in particular in construction so we
created this course to try and give you
real practical skills which you can
Implement start implementing today um so
one of the main objectives of this
course is to build a final project so
you can either use some of the templates
that we we're going to give you as part
of this course but we really want to
inspire you to go out there and to build
your own solution as well so either take
one of the templates we're giving you as
part of this course and adjust it or
fine-tune it more to what you want to
build or build your own thing from
scratch but the idea here is we want you
to build something and share it so
you're going to be invited into a
community of over 300 other Engineers
who are interested in Ai and Automation
in construction and you're going to be
invited to share your final project to
that Community as well and just a quick
introduction about myself so I'll being
the instructor for this full course so
I'm one of the founders of civil's AI my
background is actually in construction I
was mainly working on tunneling projects
as a consultant as a designer I taught
myself coding over about 5 years um and
then ended up leaving my corporate job
in order to uh join a startup incubator
with some idea of building uh AI
automation for construction because not
really anyone was doing it at the time
so this was almost 3 years ago now and
uh created civil's AI I raised some
money from Venture Capital met my two
co-founders on this startup incubation
program and yeah we've since grown
civil's AI into one of the fastest
growing construction Tech startups in
the world so what I'm going to do here
is I'm going to try and condense three
years of like AI development um failures
and uh yeah experiments into just a
succinct course which is seven lesson
seven hours long earn seven lessons and
explain to you everything that I learned
on the way and just try to help you get
to a good level as quickly as possible
so this brings us to the end of the
introduction and I hope you're ready and
excited to start learning more about Ai
and start building AI applications for
construction so let's get started and
see you in the next lesson